we got breaking news out of Provo Utah a
man who was posting threats against the
president had his home raided by the FBI
where he was shot and killed and this
story is uh currently spreading hundreds
of thousands of tweets as everyone's
talking about it and there's a couple
different views either way I see it as
escalation you either have the story of
a deranged man on the internet
threatening to harm the president
or you have the story of an overzealous
FBI targeting a morbidly obese elderly
man who was a threat to no one either
way you break it both sides are looking
at this as some kind of escalation and
there's a lot more than just that we're
now learning that Twitter was fined 350
000 for snubbing the FBI subpoena they
were trying to dig into Trump's social
media and apparently Twitter in some way
obstructed them
Elon Musk has previously stated that the
government had full access to everyone's
private messages their DMS and it seems
uh in all likelihood Elon was actually
blocking this